alright hello everyone let's get started
I want to talk about a system called
certificate transparency today and this
is a bit of a departure from most of the
topics we talked about so far we've
talked about distributed systems that
are really closed systems where all the
participants are trustworthy they're all
maybe be run being run by the same sort
of mutually trusting organization like
rafters that way you know you just
assume at the RAF's tiers do what
they're supposed to do but there's also
plenty of systems out there particularly
systems sort of built an internet scale
where the systems are open and anyone
can participate being active participant
I mean in some big systems out there and
if you build systems that are completely
open in that way there's often no single
universally trusted Authority that
everybody is willing to trust to run the
system or to protect it that is
everybody you sort of potentially
mutually suspicious of everyone else and
if that's the situation you have to be
able to build useful systems out of
mutually distrusting pieces and this
makes in any sort of internet wide open
systems to make trust and security sort
of top level systems issues when you're
thinking about designing a distributed
system so the most basic question when
you're building an open system is when
I'm talking to another computer or
another person you need to know are you
talking to the right other computer or
are you talking to the right website and
this problem is actually close to
unsolvable it turns out there's really
there's lots of solutions and none
really work that well but it is the
problem that certificate transparency
today's topic is trying to help with the
material today ties sort of backwards in
the course to consistency it turns out
that a lot of what certificate
transparency do doing is ensuring that
all parties see
the same information about certificates
that's a real consistency issue and this
material also ties forward to blockchain
systems like blockchain which is what we
talk talking about next week a
certificate transparency is among the
relatively few non cryptocurrency uses
of a blockchain like design alright so
by way of introduction I want to start
with the situation on the web with web
security at any rate as it existed
before 1995 before certificates so this
is for 1995 and in particular there was
a there was a kind of attack in those
days that people were worried about
called a man-in-the-middle attacks this
is man in
middle and this is a name for a class of
attacks style of attack so you know the
set up in those days is you have the
internet and you have people running
browsers
um sitting with our computer attached to
the Internet
anyone sitting in front of my computer I
want to talk to a specific server
exposing what I want to do is talk to
gmail.com right and ordinarily I would
you know maybe contact the DNS system I
would as a user I maybe type gmail.com I
would sort of know what it was I wanted
to talk to name Li gmail.com my browser
would talk to DNS servers say what's
gmail.com it would reply with a IP
address I connected that IP address and
you know I need to authenticate myself
so I'd probably type my password to
Gmail to Gmail's website and then Gmail
would show me my email without some kind
of story for security this system is
actually quite easy to attack and turn
out to be easy to attack and the one
style of attack is that what's called a
man-in-the-middle attack where some evil
person sets up a another web server that
serves pages that look just like Gmail
web servers like the last for your login
and password right and then the attacker
would maybe intercept my DNS packets or
just guess when I would have sent a DNS
packet and come up with a fake reply
that instead of providing the real IP
address of the real gmail.com server
would provide the email address of ma of
the attackers fake computer and then the
user's browser instead of talking to
Gmail would actually unknown to them be
talking to the attackers computer the
attackers computer would provide a web
page looks just like a login page user
types are paths log and a password and
now the attackers computer can forward
that to the real Gmail login for you of
course you don't know that you know get
your current inbox back to the attackers
computer which presumably records it
along with your password and then sends
your inbox or whatever to the browser
and this allows a you know if you can
execute this kind of man-in-the-middle
attack the attackers computer can record
your password record your email and
you'll never be the wiser
and
before certificates on SSL and HTTPS
there was really no defense against this
mom okay so this is the man in the
middle attack and this attacker here is
the man in the middle looks just like
Gmail to the browser pretends to be the
user when talking to Gmail so that it
can actually get the information from
Gmail required to trick the user into
thinking it's really Gmail all right so
this is the attack in the mid-90s people
came up with certificates with SSL or
it's also called TLS it's what the
protocol the security protocol that
you're using when you use HTTPS links um
and here the game was that Gmail comm
was gonna have a public/private key pair
so we'd have a private key that only
Gmail knows sitting in its server and
then when you connect well your the user
you connect somewhere you ask to connect
to Gmail you know and in order to verify
that you're really talking to Gmail the
users going to demand Gmail prove that
it really owns Gmail is private key well
of course
where does your browser find out Gmail
is private key from your Gmail public
key which is what you need to check that
it really has the private key there's
also this notion of certificate
authorities and certificates so there'd
be a certificate authority when Gmail
set up its server it would contact the
certificate authority may be on the
phone or by email or something and say
look you know I want a certificate for
the DNS name gmail.com and the
certificate authority would sort of try
to verify that oh yes whoever's asking
for certificate really owns that name
it really is Google or whoever owns
gmail.com and if so the certificate
authority would provide a certificate
back to gee
komm which basically what a certificate
contains is the name of the web server
the web servers public key and a
signature over this certificate made
with the certificate authorities private
key so this is sort of a self-contained
assertion checkable by checking the
signature an assertion by the
certificate authority that the public
key of gmail.com is really this public
key gmail.com server would I just keep a
copy of the certificate if you connect
to gmail.com server with HTTPS the first
thing it does is sends you back this
certificate at this point is just a
certificate right now of course since
gmail.com is willing to give it to
anybody it's the certificate itself is
not at all pregnant it's quite public
and then the browser would send some
information like a random number for
example to the server and ask it to sign
it with its private key and then the
browser can check using the public key
in the certificate that the random
number is ran and remember was really
signed by the private key that's
associated with the public key in the
certificate and therefore that whoever
it's talking to is really the entity
that the certificate authority believes
is gmail.com all right and now the
reason why this makes man-in-the-middle
attacks much harder is that yeah you
know you can set up a rogue server that
looks just like Gmail calm and maybe you
can even hack the DNS system indeed you
still can if you're sufficiently clever
powerful hack the DNS system to tell
people's browsers that oh they should go
to your server instead of gmail.com but
once somebody's browser contacts your
server
you're not presumably going to be able
to produce a certificate that says but
you you can produce Gmail certificate
but then Gmail certificate as Gmail's
public key your server doesn't have
their private key so you can
sign the challenge the browser sent you
and presumably since you're not the real
Google and not the real Gmail you're not
going to be able to persuade a
certificate authority to give you a
certificate associating gmail comm with
your public key that unit and so this
certificate scheme made
man-in-the-middle attacks quite a bit
harder and you know indeed they are
quite a bit harder now because of
certificates okay so it turns out though
that the certificate scheme as people
now have a lot of experience with it
almost 25 years experience within so we
now know there's some kind of things
that go wrong it was originally imagined
that there would just be a couple of
trustworthy certificate authorities who
would do a good job of checking that
request really came from who they
claimed to come from that if somebody
asked for a certificate for gmail.com
that this certificate authorities would
indeed actually verified that the
request came from the owner gmail.com
and not hand out certificates to random
people for gmail comp but it that turns
out to be very challenging for google
maybe you can convince this certificate
authority can convince itself that a
request comes from Google but you know
for just XCOM that's very hard to have a
certificate authority reliably able to
say oh yeah gosh this request really
came from the person who really does own
the DMS name XCOM all right a worse
problem is that while originally they
were envisioned there'd be only a few
certificate authority there are now
literally hundreds of certificate
authorities out there and any
certificate authority can generate a
certificate for any name and indeed may
want to you're allowed to change
certificate authorities if you're a
website owner you can change certificate
authority to whoever you like so there's
no sense in which certificate
authorities have limits on their powers
they can any certificate authority can
produce any certificate and now browsers
have you know there's a couple hundred
certificate authorities and that means
that each browser has built into it like
Chrome or Firefox or something has built
into it a list of the public keys of all
the certificate all couple hundred sort
good authorities and if any of them sign
has signed a certificate produced by web
server certificates acceptable the
result of this is that there have been
multiple incidents of certificate
authorities producing bogus certificates
that is producing certificates that said
they were certificate for Google or
Gmail or some other real company but
were actually issued to someone totally
else absolutely not issued certificate
for one of Google's names but not issued
to Google issued to someone else like
and you know sometimes this happens just
by mistake because superior Authority
doesn't realize that they're doing the
wrong thing and sometimes it's actually
quite malicious I mean there have
certainly been certificates issued to
people who just wanted to snoop on
people's traffic and mount
man-in-the-middle attacks and did
Mountain Man the middle attacks today's
readings are mentioned a couple of these
incidents and they're particularly
troubling because they're hard to
prevent because there's so many
certificate authorities and not all of
them
although sorry the last question let was
the last line insert box it's a
signature over the certificate by the
sir tip using by the certificate
authorities using the certificate
authorities private key okay so there
have been incidents of bogus
certificates certificates for real
websites like Google issued to totally
the wrong people and those certificates
have been abused and it's not clear how
to fix the certificate authority system
itself to prevent them because there's
so many certificate authorities and they
really you just can't expect that
they're going to be completely reliable
so what can we do about this one
possibility would be to have a single
online database of all valid
certificates so that when a browser
you know browser Comcast websites web
site hands at a certificate you know
might or might be valid then maybe you
could imagine the browser would contact
the global valid certificate database
ins assays this really is certificate
a bogus certificate issued by a row
certificate authority um the problem is
as many problems with that approach one
is it's still not clear how you can how
anybody can distinguish valid correctly
issued certificates from bogus
certificates because typically you just
don't know who the proper owner of DNS
names it is furthermore you need to
allow certificate owners to change
certificate authorities or renew their
certificates or they may lose their
private key and need a new certificate
to replace their older to think because
using a new public/private key pair so
people's certificates change all the
time and finally even if technically or
were possible to distinguish correct
certificates from bogus ones
there's no entity that everybody would
trust to do it you know everybody in the
world those you know the Chinese
Iranians the Americans you know there's
not any one outfit that they all trust
and that's the root reason why there's
so many certificate authorities so we
really can't you really can't expect
there to be a single Clearing House that
accurately distinguishes between valid
and invalid certificates however what
certificate authority certificate
transparency doing is doing is
essentially try not do the best that
it's possible to do you know the longest
step it can towards a database of the
holid trustworthy certificates so now
I'm gonna give an overview of the
general strategy of certificate
transparency the style of certificate
transparency is that it's an audit
system because it's so hard hard to
impossible to just decide does this
person own a name a certificate
transparency isn't a building a system
that prevents bad things from happening
which would require you to be able to
detect right away that as
certificate was bogus instead
certificate transparency is going to
enable audit that is it'll it's a system
to cause all the information to be
public so that it can be inspected by
people who care that is it's gonna if
you know maybe people it'll still allow
people to issue bogus certificates but
it's gonna insure those certificates are
public and that everybody can see them
including whoever it is that owns the
name that the name that's in the bogus
certificate and so this fixes the
problem with the pre certificate
transparency system where certificate
authorities could issue bogus
certificates and no one would ever know
and they could even give them to victim
a few victim browsers who would be
tricked by them and still because
certificates aren't generally public
they could somebody could a certificate
authority could issue a bogus
certificate for anybody for Google or
Microsoft and Google Microsoft might
never realize it and the incidents that
have come to light have generally been
discovered only by accident not because
they were sort of foredoomed to be
discovered so instead of relying on
accidental discovery of bogus
certificates certificate transparency
it's going to sort of force them into
the light where they is much easier to
notice them again so it has a sort of
audit flavor or nada not a prevention
flavor okay so the basic structure again
we have gmail.com or some other service
that wants a certificate as usual
they're gonna ask someone of the
hundreds of CAS for a certificate when
when when the cert web servers first set
up so we're gonna ask a certificate and
the certificate authority is gonna send
this certificate back to the web server
because of course is the web server that
gives a certificate to the browser and
at the same time though the certificate
authority is going to send a copy of the
certificate or equivalent information to
a sort
Transparency vlog server there's gonna
the real system there's multiple
independent certificate transparently
log servers i can assume there's just
one so this is some service that you
know we don't have turns out we're not
gonna have to trust the certificate
authorities gonna send it certificate to
this certificate log service which has
been maintaining a log of all issued
certificates or all ones that
certificate authorities have told it
about when it gets a new certificate
it's gonna append it to its log so this
you know might have millions of
certificates in it after a while now
when the browser and some human wants to
talk to a website they you know they
talk did set up an HTTPS connection to
Gmail Gmail sends them a certificate
back and the browser's gonna send that
certificate to the certificate log
server see is this certificate in the
log there's difficut log servers gonna
say yes or no is their certificate in
the log now and if it is then the
browser will go ahead and use it now the
fact that it's in the log you know
doesn't mean it's not bogus right
because any certificate authority
including the ones that are out there
that are malicious or badly run any
certificate authority can insert a
certificate into the log system and
therefore perhaps trick users into using
it so for so far we haven't built a
system that prevents abuse however it is
the case that no browser will use a
certificate unless it's in the log so at
the same time gmail is going to run up
with the CT system calls a monitor and
for now well
just assume that there's a monitor
associated with every website so this
monitor periodically also talks to the
certificate log servers an asset please
give me a copy of your log or really you
know please give me a copy of whatever
new has been added to your long since I
last asked and that means that the
monitor is going to build up it's going
to be aware of every single certificate
that's going to be enough that's in the
log and but also because the monitor is
associated with Gmail the monitor knows
what Gmail's correct certificate is so
if some rogue certificate authority
issues a certificate for Gmail it's not
the one that Gmail itself asked for then
Gmail's monitor will stumble across it
in the certificate log because Gmail's
monitor knows Gmail's correct
certificate now of course the rogue
certificate authority doesn't have to
send its certificate to the certificate
log system but in that case when
browsers you know maybe accidentally
connect to the attackers web server and
the attacker would swipe server gives
them the bogus certificate if they
haven't put it in the log then the
browser won't believe it and will abort
the connection it's not because it's not
in the log
so the log sort of forces because
browsers require certificates being a
log the log forces all certificates to
be public where they can be audited and
checked by monitors who know what the
proper certificates our and so some
monitors are run by big companies and
companies know their own certificates
some monitors are run by certificate
authorities on behalf of their customers
and again those certificate authorities
know what certificates they've issued to
their customers and they can at least
alert their customers if they see a
certificate they didn't issue for one of
their customers names I'm in addition
there's some totally third-party monitor
systems where you give the third-party
monitor your names and yours and your
valid certificates and it checks for
expected certificates for your names
alright this is the overall scheme but
it depends very much on browsers seeing
the very same log contents that monitors
see and but remember we were up against
this problem that we're not sure that we
can trust any component in this system
so indeed we found this certificate
authorities some of them are malicious
or have employees who can't be trusted
or are sloppy and don't follow the rules
so we're going to assume we have to
assume that the same will be true the
certificate log servers that some of
them will be malicious some of them may
conspire with rogue certificate
authorities and intentionally try to
help them issue bogus certificates some
of them may be sloppy some of them may
be legitimate but maybe some of their
employees or are corruptible you pay
them being a bribe so I'll do something
funny to the log delete something or add
something to it so what we need to build
is a log that even though the log
operator may be not cooperating not
trustworthy we can still be sure or at
least know if it's not the case that
browsers are seeing the same log contest
as monitors so if our browser uses a
certificate that was in the log the
monitor who owns that name will
eventually see it so what we need to do
is we need to build a log system that is
append-only so that it can't show a
certificate to a browser then delete it
before monitors see it so append-only
no Forks
in the sense that we don't want the log
system to basically keep two logs one of
which it shows two browsers and one of
which shows two monitors so we need no
Forks and we need untrusted we can't be
sure that the certificate servers are
correct so just to back up a bit the
critical properties we need for the log
system so larger than just a log servers
but the entire system of the log servers
plus the various checks is we have to
prevent deletion that is we need the
logs to be append only because if a log
server could delete items out of its log
then they could effectively show a bogus
certificate to a browser claimants in
the long and maybe in the log at that
time the browser uses it but then maybe
this certificate server could delete
that certificate from its log so that by
the time the monitor's came to look at
the log the bogus certificate wouldn't
be there so we need to have a system
that either prevents deletion or at
least detects if deletion occurred so
that's the sense in which the system
needs to be append-only and we also have
to prevent what's called equivocation or
not' we have to prevent Forks or
equivalently equivocation
so you know it's
maybe the certificate log servers could
be implementing append-only logs but if
it if it uh implemented two different
depend the only logs and showed one two
browsers and show the other append-only
log two monitors then we could be in a
position where yeah you know that the
browser that we showed the log we showed
the browser's contains the bogus
certificate but the log we showed a
monitors doesn't doesn't contain the
bogus certificate so we have to rule out
equivocation to all without trusting the
servers so how can we do this now we're
getting into the kind of details that
the last of the assignments was talking
about the first step is this thing
called a Merkel tree and this is
something that's sort of that the log
servers are expected to build on top of
the log so the idea is that there's the
actual log itself which is a sequence of
certificates you know certificate one
certificate to presumably in the order
that a certificate
certificates to be added to the system
and the prime millions I'm just going to
assume there's a couple now it's gonna
turn out you know we don't want to have
the browser's have to download the whole
log and so we need tools to so that we
can allow the logging system to
basically send trustworthy summaries or
unambiguous summaries of what's in the
log to the the browsers and I'll talk in
a bit about it exactly what those
summaries are used for but the basic
scheme is that the log servers are gonna
use cryptographic hashes to sort of hash
up the complete set of records that are
in the log can produce a single
cryptographic hash which is typically
these days about 256 bits long so the
cryptographic hash summarizes the
countenance of the log and the way
that's done is that the is as a
basically a tree structure of pairs over
hash always hashing together pairs of
numbers at the zeroeth level so I'm
gonna write each for a hash each one of
the log entries has a hash so we're
gonna have sort of at the base level we
have the hash of each log entry each
certificate and then we're going to hash
up peers so that the next level we're
gonna have a hash of this and
concatenated with this and a hash of
this concatenated with this these two
hashes and then at the top level sort of
we're we're overdoing is hashing these
two the concatenation of these two
hashes and this single hash here is a
unambiguous sort of stand-in for the
complete log one of the properties of
these cryptographic hashes like sha-256
is that it's not feasible to find two
inputs to the hash function that produce
the same output and that means if you
tell somebody the output of the hash
function there's only one input you're
ever going to be able to find that
produce that output so if the log server
does hash up in this way the contents of
its logs only this sequence of these log
records will ever be able to produce
that hash or guaranteed effectively that
the log server is not going to be able
to find some other log that produces the
same final tree hash as this sequence of
log entries all right so this is the
Merkel tree this is the sort of tree
hash that summarizes the entire log at
the top of the Merkel tree there there's
will actually call it a signed tree head
because in fact the log servers take
this hash this at the top of the tree
and sign it with their private key and
give that to clients to browsers and
monitors and the fact that they've
signed it means that they they can't
disavow it later
that was really them and produced it so
that's you know just to be able to catch
lying lying log servers and so the point
here is that once a log server has
revealed a particular sign tree head to
a browser or monitor its committed to
some specific log contents because it
won't be able to ever produce a
different log contents to produce the
same hash so you hashes are really
function as kind of commitments okay so
this is the with the log but the Merkel
tree looks like for a particular log now
the third reading today sort of outlined
how to
and the law how to add records to the
log for arbitrary numbers of Records I'm
just going to assume that the log always
grows by factors of 2 which is
impractical but makes it easier to
explain Naumann so that means that as
certificate authorities send in new
certificates to add to the log the log
server will wait until it has as many
new records as it has old records and
then produce another tree head and the
way it does that is it's gonna in order
to extend the log the log servers going
to wait off as another four records and
then it's gonna hash them pairwise just
as before and then it'll produce a new
tree head that is the hash of the
concatenation of these two hashes and
this is the new tree head for the new
expanded law and so that means as time
goes on and a log server this log grows
longer and longer it produces sort of
higher and higher a sequence of higher
and higher tree heads as the logarithms
okay so this is the structure that we're
expecting log servers to maintain of
course who knows what they're actually
doing especially if they're malicious
but the protocol the certificate
transparency protocol sort of is written
you know as if the log server was was
actually doing this all right so what do
we need to do but do the point of this
Merkle trees is to use them to force log
servers to prove certain things about
the logs that they can about the log
that they're maintaining we're going to
want to know what those those proofs
look like the first kind of
is what I'll call a proof of inclusion
and this is what a
NEADS when it when it wants to find out
if a certificate that has just been
given by a web server if that
certificate is really in the law it's
gonna ask the certificate it's gonna ask
the log server look here's a certificate
you know is it an is it in your log and
the certificate server is gonna send
back a proof of actually not just that
the certificate is in the log but
actually where it is what its position
is in the log and of course the browser
wants this proof because it doesn't want
to use the certificate if it's not in
the log because if it's not I'm along
then monitors won't see it and there's
no / - no protection against their
certificate being bogus and it needs to
be a proof because we we can't afford to
let this log server a malicious log
forever change its mind we don't want to
take the log servers word for it because
then they might a malicious log server
might say yes and this proof is gonna
help us catch it you know if a log
server does lie these proofs are gonna
help us catch the fact that the log
servers lied and produce evidence that
the log server is malicious and should
be ignored from now on is that sort of
the ultimate sanction against the log
servers is that the browser's actually
have a list of acceptable log servers
and these proofs would be part of the
evidence to cause one of the log servers
to be taken out of the log if it was
malicious okay so we need a proof we
want the log server to produce a proof
that a given certificate is in its log
so actually the first step is that the
browser asks the log server for the
current sign tree head so what the
browser's really asking is is this
certificate in the log that summarized
by this current by this sign tree head
and the log server may lie about the
sign tree head right the browser asks it
for the current sign tree head and then
for a proof that the certificate is in
the log the log server could lie about
the sign tree headband will deal about
that we'll consider that later but for
now let's assume that the the browser
has the correct sign tree head and is
demanding a proof okay so for simplicity
I'm just gonna explain how to do this
for a log with two records and it turns
out that extending that to a log with
with other more higher power of two
records is relatively easy um so the
browser actually has a particular sign
tree head let's suppose the correct log
that sits under that sign tree head is
the two LM in log a B for particular
certificates a and B and that means that
the correct
Merkle tree for that it securely is at
the bottom as the hashes of a and B and
then the sign tree head is actually the
hash of a hash of a concatenated with a
hash would be so let's suppose this is
the sign tree head that the certificate
that the log server actually gave to the
client of course the client doesn't this
client only knows this value this is
final hash value doesn't actually know
what is in the log the proof if the if
the browser asked for a proof that a is
in the log then the proof that the log
server can return is simply the proof
for a is a in the log is simply eizan in
the log and the hash of the other
element in the log so zero and the hash
of b
and that is enough information for a to
convince itself that for sorry for the
client to convince itself that a really
is at position zero because it can take
it knows the certificate is interested
in it can hash it part of the proof was
the hash of the other element in this
lowest level hash so the browser can
that now knows H a and H B you can hash
them together can execute this hash and
see if the result is the same as the
sine tree head that it happens and if it
is then that means that the certificate
log is actually produce a valid proof
that certificate a is at position B
that's a sorry it's a position zero in
the log summarized by this sign tree
head and it turns out that in larger
larger logs you know if you're looking
for if you need a proof that a is really
here all you need is the sequence of
hashes of the other branch of each hash
up to the sign tree head that you have
so in a for element log if you if you
need a proof that a is position zero you
need this hash units then you need this
hash and if the lock is bigger you know
eight elements then you also need this
hash assuming that you have the signed
tree hit so you can take the element you
know and hash it together with each of
these other hashes see if it's equal to
the sign tree head okay so if the
browser asks is supposing the browser
asks whether X is in the log at position
zero well X isn't in the log right so
hopefully there's no easy way for the
log server to produce the proof that X
is in the log in position zero but
suppose the log servers wants to lie and
it's in the position where it already
exposed a sign tree head for log that
contain a and then B browser doesn't
know was a and B doesn't know what's in
the log and the log server wants to
trick the client into the browser into
thinking that it's really
at position zero well it turns out that
in order to do that the for this small
log the certificate server has to
produce for some why it needs to find a
why that if it takes it's hash one
concatenated with X you know so this is
that's that it's equal to the sign tree
head right because the client we're
assuming the client already has to sign
tree head we need to find a some number
here that when hashed together with the
hash of X that the clients asking about
produces that same sign tree hit well we
know the sign tree head or the
assumption is assigned tree it was
actually for some other log right
because we're trying to rule out the
possibility that the log server can give
you a sign tree head for one log but
that convince you that something else is
in that log that's not there so the sign
tree had really was produced by from the
hashes of the records that really were
in the log and now we need and since you
know X is definitely different from a
that means the hash of X is different
from the hash of a and that means that
the log server needs to find two
different inputs to the hash function
that produced the same output and the
Assumption widely believed to be true
for practical purposes is that that's
not possible for cryptographic hashes
therefore the cent sign tree head was
produced by hashing up one log that it
will not be possible to find these sort
of other hash values that would be
required to produce a proof that some
other element was in the log that wasn't
really there
any questions about this about anything
[Music]
interesting a nice thing about this is
that the proofs are the proofs consist
of just the sort of other hashes on the
way up to the root if there's n
certificates there's only log in other
hashes and so the proofs are reasonably
concise in particular that are much much
smaller than the full log and since you
know every browser that needs to connect
to a website he's going to need one of
these proofs it's good if they're small
okay well this was whole discussion was
assuming that the sign tree had the
theum
or had was the correct sign tree head if
the but no there's no immediate reason
to believe that the log server would
have given if the logs are is malicious
and it wants to trick a client you know
why would it give the client the correct
see sign tree head why doesn't it give
it just me giving the sign tree head for
the bogus log that it wants to trick the
client into using so we have to be
prepared for the possibility that the
log server has cooked up I just
completely different log for the browser
that's not like anybody else's log and
it just contains the bogus certificates
that a malicious log server wants to
trick this client into believing so what
do we do about that well it turns out
that this is at least in the first
instance this is totally possible
you know usually what's gonna happen
usually the way this will play out is
that we'd have some browser that was you
know seeing the correct logs until some
point in time when when somebody wanted
to attack it and you know you want the
browser student be able to use all the
websites that it's ordinarily seeing
plus a sort of different log with bogus
certificates that the log server wants
to trick just that client just that
victim browser into using so now this is
a fork fork attack or more broadly
equivocation and the reason why people
call this kind of attack
a fork attack is that if we just never
mind the Merkel tree for a moment if we
just consider the log usually the log
already has you know millions of
certificates in it and everybody's seen
the beginning part of the log then at
some point in time we want to attack we
want to persuade our victim to use some
bogus certificate B but we don't want to
show B to anybody else certainly not to
the monitor so we're gonna sort of cook
up this other log the sort of continues
as usual and contains new submissions
but definitely doesn't contain the bogus
certificate B and you know what this
looks like is a fork because both the
sort of main log that monitors are shown
is kind of off on one fork and then this
vlog we're cooking up especially to
trick a victim is a different fork this
is the construction that the malicious
log server would have to produce if it
wants to trick a browser into using a
bogus certificate and again these are
possible it's possible to do this at
least briefly in with certificate
authority the sift a fit transparency
luckily though is not the end of the
story and certificate authority contains
some tools that allow it to make Forks
much more difficult so the basic scheme
is that this isn't this is the way the
certificate authority sort of intended
to work all certificate transparency is
intended to work but doesn't quite
what's going on here is that the the the
monitors and people are not being
attacked or gonna see a a sign tree
particular sign tree head let's say
science we hit one of course is gonna
change as the log extends and the victim
we know must see some other sign tree
head because this is a signed tree hit
that is hashed over this
certificates guaranteed to be different
from the sign tree heads this is the
militia service showing two monitors
if only the browsers and monitors could
compare notes they would maybe instantly
realize that they were seeing different
trees and all it takes is comparing you
know if we play our cards right all it
takes is comparing the sign tree had its
they've gotten from the log server to
realize wait a minute we're seeing
different logs now something's terribly
wrong so the critical thing we need to
do is have have the different
participants in the system be able to
compare sign tree heads and the
certificate transparency has a provision
for this called gossip and the way it's
intended to works that browsers well the
details don't really matter but what it
really amounts to is that all the
participants sort of drop off the recent
sign tree heads they've seen into a big
pool that they all inspect to try to
figure out if there's inconsistent sign
tree heads that clearly indicate
divergent logs that have for it so we're
going to gossip which really means
exchange
I'm sign tree heads and compare it turns
out that current certificate
transparency implementations don't do
this but they ought to and they'll
figure it out at some point
all right okay so the question is given
to sign tree heads how do we decide if
they're evidence that the log has been
forked the thing that makes this hard is
that even if a log hasn't been forked as
it's depended to new sign tree heads
will become current so you know maybe
sign tree head one was the legitimate so
he had a vlog at this point of then some
more certificates are added and sign
tree head 3 becomes the correct head of
the law and then signed tree head for
etc so really what this gossip
comparison least to do is distinguish
situations where one sign tree head is
really describes a prefix a log that's a
prefix of the log described by another
sign tree head because this is the
legitimate situation where you have the
two these two sign tree heads are
different but the second one really does
subsume the first one we want to
distinguish that from two signed tree as
that are different where neither
describes a log that's a prefix of the
other one's log one tell these two cases
apart this telling that situation apart
is the purpose of the consistency proof
the log or Merkel consistency proof that
the reading is talked about so this is
the
la consistency proof
you
so the game here is that we're given to
sign tree heads H 1 and H 2 and we're
asking is h 1s log prefix really it's
not these are - these are hashes so it's
really asking about the log that the
hashes represent and you know we're
hoping the answer is yes and if the
answer's no that means that the log
servers Fork Dustin is hiding something
from one party or the other okay well it
turns out that um as we as I mentioned
before the as the Merkel tree as the log
grows the Merkel tree also grows and
what we see is a sequence of signs of
tree heads each one as a log doubles in
size each one has its as its left thing
let me draw in the actual hash functions
of this hash function is hashing up two
things the result of this hash function
is one of the inputs to the next sign
tree head the result of this hash
function is one of the inputs to the
next sign tree head I know we get this
kind of tree of life sign tree heads all
right and I need to sign tree heads if
they're legitimate you know if each one
is log is a prefix of H 2 that means
that maybe this one's H 1 and this one's
H 2 and they're gonna have this
relationship thing you know if each one
is a piece of H 2 then they must have
this relationship where each 2 was
produced by taking each one hashing it
with some other thing and maybe hashing
that with some other thing until we get
to the point where we find H 2 and with
means is that if a browser or monitor
challenges a log a log server to prove
that each one's log is really a prefix
of h2s log what the log server has to
produce is this sequence of other the
other side of each of the Hat sign tree
head hashes on the way from h1 to h2 and
this is the proof and then again you
know this is reminiscent of the
inclusion proofs then to check the proof
you need to take each one hash it with
the first other thing you know hash that
along with the second other things that
you get to the last one of these and
that had better be equal to h2 if it is
it's a proof that h2 is a suffix of each
one otherwise the log servers evidently
tried to fork you and again you know the
basis of this is that there's no other
you know h2 really isn't as supposing h1
isn't a prefix of h2 there's no way that
uh since h2 was created from some actual
log that's not the same as h1 there's no
way that the log server could cook up
these values that are required to cause
the hashes this sort of repeated hash of
h1 to equal H to H do really encompass
ooming that the cryptographic hash does
prevent you from binding to different
inputs that produce the same out
alright ok so this is the log
consistency proof okay so the question
is who usually challenges the log server
so I'll actually talk about that in a
minute but it turns out that um both
browsers and monitors
well Luke browsers and monitors
challenge the log server you it's
actually usually the browser's
challenging the log server that's the
most important thing but there's two
points in time at which you need to
challenge the log server to produce
these proofs and I'll talk about both of
them all right okay actually so the
first place at which one point at which
these proofs are used as for gossip as
part of gossip as I outlined and the the
scheme that's intended for gossip is
that browsers will periodically talk to
some central repository of some set of
central repositories and just contribute
to a pool of sign tree heads the sign
tree hits the recently seen from the log
server and the browsers were also
periodically pull out random elements of
sign tree heads that other browsers have
seen just Brandon they pulled them out
of the pool and it'll be multiple of
these collects these pools run by
different people so that if one of them
is cheating that will be proof against
that and then the browser will for
whatever just any random sign tree has
it apples out of the pool it will ask
the log server to produce the logs
insistency proof for that pair of sign
tree heads and you know if nobody's
cheating design it should always be easy
for the log server to produce you know
any consistency proof that's demanded of
it but if it's for somebody suppose it
the log server is for somebody and given
them a sign tree had this really
describes a totally different log or
even a long the difference in one
element from the logs that everybody
else is seeing eventually that browser
will contribute that's that sign tree
head to the pool the gossip pool then
eventually somebody else
we'll pull that sign tray head out of
the pool and ask for a proof for you
know some other sign tree had that
presumably is on a different Fork and
then the log server will not be able to
produce the proof and I'm since they're
signed since the scientist or signed by
the log server that's just absolute
proof that the log server has forked two
of its clients presumably with intent
reveal a bogus certificate to one of
them and hide it from the other okay but
there's actually another place where it
turns out you need the these consistency
proves not just during gossip but
actually also during the ordinary
operation of the browsers so the the
difficulty is that suppose you know
suppose the browser is it's kind of
seeing consistent version of the log is
the same as everybody else but then log
server wants to trick it into using this
bogus certificate so the log server
sends it a signed tree you know makes
signed RIA that's different from
everybody else that refers to a you know
malicious log that contains this bad
certificate preferred video since it
doesn't want other people to notice
certainly doesn't want you know the
monitors to notice you know cooks up
this other log that is what everybody
else is seeing all right so now the you
know the browser checks and sees you
know I asked for inclusion proof and the
inclusion that log server will be able
to produce the inclusion proof because
this sign tree had that the browser has
really does refer to this bad log the
browser will go ahead and use this bogus
certificate and maybe get tricked and
give away the user's password
you know who knows what but depending on
the details of other browsers work we're
at risk of the next time the browser
which it doesn't realize anything's gone
wrong talks to the log server the log
server might then say you know there's a
new log with a bunch of new stuff on it
and here is the sign tree
of the current log why don't you switch
my to use that as your sign tree hit and
so now if that were allowed to happen
then the browser's now would completely
lost the evidence that anything went
wrong because now the browser is using
the same trees everybody else no it's
going to contribute this sign tree head
to the gossip pool it's all gonna look
good and we had this sort of brief evil
tree that was evil log that was revealed
evil log Fork but if the browser's are
willing to accept a new sign tree head
then we can basically have the browser
forget about so we want what we want is
this what we want is for if a browser if
the log service shows a particular log
to the browser that the browser that
they can't trick the browser into
switching away from that log that is
that we want to be able to enforce that
the browser sees only strict extensions
to the log that it's seen already and
doesn't simply get switched to a log
that is not compatible with the log the
browser seen before it's the property
that we're looking for it's actually
called for consistency and with any
first two is that if the browser's been
forked onto a different fork from other
people then they must stay on that fork
in it it should never be able to switch
to the main fork and the reason for that
is we want to preserve you need to
preserve this bad sign tree head and its
successors so that when the browser
participates in the gossip protocol it's
contributing sign tree heads that nobody
else has and that cannot be proved to be
compatible using the log consistency
proof okay so how do we achieve for
consistency well um it's actually easy
with the tools we have now every time
the log server tells a browser oh here's
a new sign tree head for a longer log
the browser will require the will not
accept the new sign tree head until the
log server has has produced a log
consistency proof that the new sign tree
head describes a suffix of the old sign
tree that is that the log of the old
sign tree has a prefix of the log of the
new sign tree and of course if a log
server is as forked the browser and it's
keeping the browser on that same Fork it
can produce the proofs but of course you
know it's digging its grave even deeper
because I'm as producing more and more
sign tree heads for a which will
eventually be caught by the gossip
protocol whereas if the blog server
tries to cause the browser to switch to
a sign tree head that describes the same
log everybody else has been seeing the
browser will demand a consistency proof
and the log server will not be able to
produce it because deed the log
described by the first sign tree head is
not a prefix of the log described by the
second sign tree
okay okay so the system these these log
consistency proofs provide for
consistency and for consistency plus
gossiping and that requiring this log
consistency proves for the science found
by gossiping
I'm the two of them together make it
likely that all the participants or
seeing the same log and that if they're
not seeing the same log they'll be able
to detect that fact by the failure of a
log consistency proof
any questions
okay so that how many log service are
there that is a great question
so I describe the system as if there was
just one log server it turns out in the
real system there's lots of log servers
at least dozens so this is a deployed
system which you can programmed in that
is actually used by Chrome and I think
Safari there are at least dozens of
these log servers and when certificate
and certificate authorities are actually
required by chrome to submit all their
certificates to the to the log servers
to multiple log servers the different
log servers don't actually keep
identical logs the convention is that a
certificate authority will submit a new
certificate to save you know a couple
maybe five different log servers and
actually in the certificate information
that a website tells your browser it
includes the identities of log servers
of the certificate transparency log
servers that have the certificate in
their log so your browser knows which
log servers to talk to and the reason
why there's more than one of them is of
course some of them may go bad some of
them may turn out to be malicious or go
out of business or who knows what and in
that case you still want to have a
couple more to fall back on they don't
have to be identical because they don't
as long as the certificate is in at
least one log that's you know as far as
anybody knows is trustworthy that's
sufficient because you know the issue
here
not really necessarily the fact that the
log had the certificate in it because
that's not proof that the certificate is
good all we're looking for is log
servers that aren't forking the monitors
and browsers that use them so it's
enough for a certificate to be in even a
single log server that's not forking
people because then the monitors are
guaranteed to see it because the
monitors check all the log servers so if
a bogus certificate shows up even even a
single log server the monitors will
eventually notice because all the
monitors look at all the log servers
that the browsers are willing to accept
all right another question what prevents
a log server from going down and issuing
bogus certificates before they get
caught you know nothing actually if
you're willing to that's definitely a
defect in the system that at least for a
while you can
malicious log server contributing bogus
certificates so if you have a
certificate authority that's become
malicious and this issuing bogus
certificates they look correct but
they're bogus and a log server then that
that's willing to serve these it's
willing to put these certificates in the
log and of course they all are then at
least for a while browsers will be
willing to use them the thing is though
that the you know they will be caught
and this is the system is its intent is
to improve the situation in the priests
or to make a transparency system if
somebody was issuing bogus certificates
and browsers were being tricked into
using them you might never find out ever
in the certificate transparency world
you may not find out right away and so
some some people may use them but then
relatively quickly you know a few days
or something the monitors will start to
notice that there's bad certificates in
the logs and somebody will go and track
it down and figure out who is malicious
or who is making mistakes
yeah so I guess a certificate a
certificate transparency law could
refuse to talk to the monitors yeah I'm
not sure I think ultimately the if you
know we're now treading into a kind of
non-technical region you know what to do
if there's evidence that something's
gone wrong this is actually quite hard
because much of the time is something
seems to go wrong even bogus
certificates often often the reason it's
just somebody made a mistake it was a
legitimate mistake you know somebody
blew it and it's not evidence of malice
is just that somebody made a mistake I
think what would happen if a monitor was
misbehaving in almost any way like not
answering requests if it was doing
consistently people notice and either
ask them to shape up or take them out of
the list
stop using them the browser vendors
would take that logs her out of a list
of acceptable log servers after a while
but yeah there's like a gray area of bad
behavior that's not bad enough to the
warrant being taken out of the
acceptable list I think of a log server
has been found to work the question is
what if the log server has been found
before what happens then I think I think
what would happen is the people who were
run you know the people who the browser
vendors would talk to the log server and
ask them the people running the log
server and ask them what happened and if
they came up with a convincing
explanation that they didn't made a
mistake you know which maybe they
couldn't maybe I don't know they their
machine crashes it loses part of their
log they restart you know starting from
a prefix of the log and start growing a
different log if it seems like a mistake
honest mistake then well it was a
mistake but if it if the log server
operators can't provide a convincing
explanation of what happened then I
think the browser vendors would just
delete them from the list of acceptable
klog servers okay but these are you know
these are sort of problems with the
system because you can you know the
definitions of like who owns a name or
what acceptable but you know whether
it's okay for your server to be down or
not these are very hard to pin down
properties you know I think the system
is not full you could definitely get
away with bad behavior at least for a
while but the hope is that there's
strong enough auditing here that if some
certificate authority or log server was
persistently badly behaved that people
would notice the monitors would notice
they may not do anything for a while but
eventually they would decide that you
know you're either too much of a pain or
to malicious to be part of the system
and delete you from the browser lists of
course they split the browser vendors in
a position of quite strong power so Wow
the system is in general pretty
decentralized yeah there can be lots of
certificate authorities and lots of
certificate transparency log servers
there's only a handful of browser
vendors and that there because they
maintain the lists of acceptable
certificate authorities and log servers
they do have a lot of power and you know
it's the way it is unfortunately okay so
things to take away from a certificate
transparency design so one thing is the
key property it has super important is
just that everyone sees the same log
even if some of the parties are
malicious either everyone sees the same
long or they can accumulate evidence
from failed proofs that something's
funny is going on and because both
browsers who are using those
certificates and the owners of the DNS
names who are running monitors see the
same log because of these proofs
the monitors can detect problems and
therefore the browser's even though the
browsers can't actually detect bogus
certificates they can at least be
confident that there if there's bogus
certificates out there that monitors
will detect them and possibly put them
on revocation lists actually that's
something I didn't mention if if there's
evidence of a monitor spots what must be
a bogus certificate like MIT sees
somebody they don't know about being
issued a certificate for MIT did you it
turns out there's a pre-existing
revocation service that you can put bad
certificates on that the browser's check
so if a monitor sees a bogus certificate
it can actually be effectively disabled
by putting it on in the revocation
certificate revocation system that's not
part of certificate transparency it's
been around for a long time okay so the
key property is everyone sees the same
log of certificates another thing to
take away from this is that if you can't
figure out a way to prevent bad behavior
maybe you can build something these
usable that relies on auditing instead
of preventing that is can detect bad
things after the fact that might be good
enough it's often much easier than
preventing the bad things some technical
ideas are here in this this work one is
this idea of equivocation that I'm a big
danger is the possibility that a
malicious server will sort of provide
split views one viewed one set of people
another view to another set of people
it's usually called a fork or
equivocation it's an important kind of
attack another property this for
consistency property it turns out it's
often valuable to when you're worried
about Forks to build a system that
forces the malicious server once it has
formed somebody to keep them on that
fork so it can't erase evidence by
erasing a fork I'm the final technical
trick is the notion of gossiping in
order to detect for because it's
actually gen if the participants don't
communicate with each other it's
actually typically not possible to
notice that there has been a fork so if
you want to detect Forks there has to be
one way or another
some kind of gossip some kind of
communication between the parties so
they can compare notes and detect forks
and we'll see most of these things again
next week when we look at Bitcoin and
that's all I had to say